[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la libye dévasté
par des années de guerre civile
ce pays a aujourd'hui une chance de
renaître de ses cendres un processus de
paix démarre enfin mais il est lent
alors quelles sont ses chances d'aboutir
le gouvernement d'union nationale de
fayez al sa rage contre l'armée
nationale libyenne du maréchal khalifa
haftar un conflit interminable dont la
fin est peut-être proche le 15 novembre
le forum de dialogue politique et bien
adopté une feuille de route afin
d'ouvrir une période de transition une
avancée majeure qui fait suite à la
signature du cessez le feu nationale le
23 octobre à genève
aujourd'hui pourtant le gouvernement
d'union nationale d'al saraï menace d'en
sortir accusant les forces pro haftar
d'une violation des accords à
l'international ce cessez le feu même
fragile est accueilli plus tôt avec
enthousiasme sauf par la turquie qui
donne l'impression de vouloir continuer
à défendre ses intérêts via les forces
d'assad
les gros acteurs du conte adverses sont
l'egypte et les émirats arabes unis qui
se range du côté du maréchal haftar en
juillet le parlement égyptien autorise
même l'intervention militaire en libye
endroit que le président égyptien n'a
pas encore utilisé
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur les deux dirigeants qui
veulent l'intégralité de ce pays déchiré
c'est le blick
ça fait plus de quatre ans que fayez al
s'arrache dirige le gouvernement d'union
nationale n'ayant pas beaucoup
d'expérience politique cet homme
d'affaires est architecte et choisit à
ce poste en 2015 par les deux parlements
rivaux siégeant l'un à tripoli et
l'autre à tobrouk
pourtant ce dernier change d'avis et
refuse d'accorder le vote de confiance
au nouveau premier ministre
l'une des raisons de cette volte face et
le refus d'un sa rage de réserver une
place dans son gouvernement au maréchal
khalifa haftar officiers de l'armée et
ex proche de kadhafi
il est officiellement nommé à la tête de
l'armée nationale libyenne en 2015 par
le parlement de tobrouk
or il a dirige de facto depuis 2011
l'année de son retour en libye
après 20 ans d'exil aux états unis en
quelques années de combat a pas réussi à
prendre le contrôle sur la majorité du
pays
de son côté le gouvernement d'union
nationale présidé par fayez al saraï
exerce son contrôle sur de vastes
territoires au nord ouest du pays y
compris la capitale tripoli pourtant ni
l'un ni l'autre ne sont intervenus dans
la partie méridionale de la libye qui
fait l'objet de combats incessants entre
les milices locales dans le conflit
libyen les lignes commencent à bouger en
novembre les principales forces
politiques du pays ainsi que les
représentants de la société civile
libyenne parviennent à s'accorder sur
une feuille de route afin de démarrer la
transition politique
ce progrès est devenu possible grâce à
un accord sur le cessez le feu signé en
octobre par les parties au conflit
une réussite largement saluée à
l'international un certain nombre
d'états européens est allé encore plus
loin en menaçant de sanctions tout ce
qui empêche le processus de paix en
libye pourront elles dissuader un nombre
d acteurs étrangers impliqués dans ce
conflit
par exemple la turquie et le qatar
viennent de signer en août un accord de
coopération militaire avec le
gouvernement d'alpha rage alors que
l'egypte soutenus par les émirats arabes
unis menacent de mener une intervention
militaire au côté du maréchal haftar
pour cela le président égyptien a
d'ailleurs déjà reçu le feu vert de son
parlement
mais va-t-il usé de ce droit alors quels
sont les acteurs étrangers impliqués
dans le conflit libyen
et quel intérêt poursuivent-t-ils
pourquoi aucune tentative d'arrêter ce
conflit n'a jamais abouti jusqu'ici
enfin quelles difficultés empêche
l'avancée du processus de paix pour
répondre à toutes ces questions nous
rejoignons david rigoulet roze
chercheurs à l'ifas chercheur associé
aussi à l'iris et rédacteur en chef de
la revue orient stratégique
monsieur rigoler rose bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord parlons du nouveau
processus de paix entamé en libye pensez
vous que les personnes choisies par le
nu pour le forum de dialogue politique
représente bien toutes les forces
politiques et la société libyenne
ou alors si le problème parce
qu'effectivement le forum du dialogue
politique comprend 75 membres deux fois
26 pour chacune des deux parties
géographie de la libye et puis 49 manche
choisi par la manul c'est à dire la
mission de soutien des nations unies en
libye avec un certain nombre de femmes
et l'ensemble étant censé représenter
les temps de l'essentiel des
circonscriptions géographique sociale et
politique du pays
il ya un certain nombre de critiques qui
ont été formulées notamment certains
détracteurs fait remarquer que certaines
tribus du sud notamment toubous touareg
n était pas repris pleinement
représentés et et que ça d'une certaine
manière ça a confirmé la dissociation
entre entre le sud et la libye littoral
et donc c'est une partie des critiques
qui avaient été qui sont formulées
actuellement mais en tout cas l'onu a
considéré que le format raw qui devait
faire avancer la situation
les élections législatives et
présidentielles sont pour l'instant
prévues pour la fin de 2021
cependant ces dates est elle trop
prématuré il y a même pas encore de de
constitution en libye permanente qui
mentionne justement le poste de
président il n'existe pas encore ce
poste oui non il n'existe pas
effectivement et d'ailleurs ça fait
partie de
des tractations qui ont lieu à la faveur
des multiples réunions qui se sont
déroulées durant le mois de novembre
2020 en plusieurs endroits différents
il s'agissait effectivement d'établir
d'abord la pérennité du cessez le feu
qui avait établi le 24 octobre dernier
et puis de mettre en place les jalons
pour nommer justement trois membres du
conseil présidentiel d'un futur
conseiller présidentiel du chef du
gouvernement transitoire unifiée pour
organiser justement les élections
présidentielle et législatives fin fin
décembre donc la situation est pour
l'instant n'est pas encore totalement
clarifiée
mais il ya une roadmap qui a été qui a
été adoptée et justement pour avancer
dans cette dans ce processus
dans cette configuration cette nouvelle
configuration quelle sera selon vous
l'avenir d'un serrage est de khalifa
haftar ils sont d'une certaine manière
les deux personnes clés d'une période
qui vient de s'achever un avec justement
le lancement de cette ce processus
politique qui a été saluée par un par
l'onu avec toutes les incertitudes qui
prévalent le feuillage charasse d'une
façon a signalé à la mi septembre qu'ils
étaient des missionnaires qui d'une
certaine manière qu'ils le qui
accompagnait le processus en cours et le
marshall haftar avait vu sa position
fragilisée devant aller en juin 2020 de
du fait de l'échec de la prise du
contrôle de tripoli au profit justement
d'autres personnalités de l'est
éventuellement à gagner la salle et issa
chef du parlement de l'est aujourd'hui
avec ghazi et donc on peut effectivement
voir qu'il ya il ya aussi des
incertitudes sur les interlocuteurs sur
le même s'ils sont pas mis de côté
totalement en tout cas il ya clairement
quelque chose qui est en train de se
mettre en place pour faire émerger
éventuellement de nouvelles figures
monsieur rigolo heureuse merci beaucoup
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons en deuxième partie de
l'émission
pour plus de détails sur cette question
merci encore
le 9 novembre un forum de dialogue
politique les biens démarre à tunis sous
l'égide des nations unies
il rassemble 75 délégué es sélectionné
par le nu qui représente tout l'éventail
sociale et politique de la société
libyenne
l'objectif de cette rencontre est de
dresser les contours d'une feuille de
route politique pour parvenir à une paix
durable après une semaine de pourparlers
nombre d'avancées voit finalement le
jour
les délégués réussissent à s'entendre
sur la date des élections nationales à
la fois législatives et présidentielle
elle se déroulerait le 24 décembre 2021
jour anniversaire de l'indépendance du
pays
seul problème en libye le poste de
président n'existe pas c'est pour cela
qu'une partie des forces politiques
libyennes insiste sur l'adoption de la
nouvelle constitution avant la tenue du
scrutin national tout dialogue dont les
résultats ne mène pas directement
référendum sur le projet de constitution
mais conduisent à deux étapes de
transition ne nous conduiront pas ce que
l'écrasante majorité des libyens à temps
pour l'instant aucune décision n'est
prise au sujet du référendum
constitutionnel et les ambiguïtés
persistent au sujet du scrutin
présidentiel pourtant en ce qui concerne
la transition politique les choses sont
plus claires pendant la période
transitoire le pouvoir exécutif serait
exercée par deux institutions le conseil
présidentiel est le nouveau gouvernement
d'union nationale le premier dirigerait
les forces armées et formeraient la
ligne politique du pays à
l'international
il serait composé du président du
conseil et de ses deux adjoints tous les
trois seraient issus de trois régions
libyennes différentes tripolitaine et
cyrénaïque et faisant
le gouvernement quant à lui assurerait
le reste des fonctions exécutives la
politique économique et sociale
et c'est le plus important
l'organisation des élections prévues
pour la fin 2021
pourtant la composition de ces
institutions est encore un sujet de
discussion le coup d'envoi de ce
processus de paix est donnée le 23
octobre ce jour la commission militaire
libyenne formé de cinq responsables
militaires des deux côtés du conflit
signe à genève un cessez le feu
nationale et permanent avec effet
immédiat
il doit s'accompagner d'un retrait de
tous les mercenaires et combattants
étrangers du territoire libyen une
mesure qui est peut-être à l'origine du
scepticisme de la turquie principal
allié du gouvernement d'union nationale
de fayez al sa rage ankara a par
ailleurs déployé à bon nombre de
conseillers militaires en libye qu'elle
souhaite utiliser pour peser sur le
destin les biens elle l'accord de
cessez-le-feu de ce jour n'a pas été
conclue au plus haut niveau mais à un
niveau moindre
pour moi il semble manquer de
crédibilité à l'international cette
position est plutôt exceptionnelle par
exemple l'allemagne la france l'italie
et le royaume-uni parle d'une avancée
majeure dans le processus de paix et
menace de sanctions tous ceux qui
mettent les bâtons dans les roues au
dialogue politique en libye
l'allemagne la france l'italie le
royaume-uni appelle l'ensemble des
parties libyennes et internationales à
s'abstenir de toute initiative parallèle
et non concertée qui risquerait de saper
les efforts menés sous l'égide des
nations unies
nous sommes prêts à prendre des mesures
contre les acteurs qui nuisent au forum
de dialogue politique inter libyen
pourtant la menace principale au cessez
le feu vient plutôt des parties elles
mêmes en conflit le 6 décembre
les forces armées du gène accusé me
pro haftar d'être à l'origine d'une
attaque contre l'un de leurs camps dans
la ville du bac les combats reprennent
les forces du général al tard cette fois
ci du terrain nous avertissons les
nations unies les pays qui soutiennent
la paix le dialogue en libye que s'il ne
freine pas le criminel de guerre haftar
et ne met pas un terme à son imprudence
alors nous nous retirerons de l'accord
militaire 5 + 5
comment le conflit les biens peut-il
évoluer vu le nombre de pays impliqués
qui soutient le g et nadal sa rage ou le
maréchal haftar cherche-t-il de l'aide
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
une lueur d'espoir apparaît enfin pour
le conflit libyen les deux camps
adverses réussissent à s'entendre sur le
début d'une période de transition
principale médiatrice le nu se montre
optimiste quant à l'avenir de ce
dialogue pourtant va-t-il vraiment se
poursuivre trois ans après la chute de
kadhafi la libye est déchirée par un
conflit entre deux parlements rivaux le
premier est le congrès général national
dont le siège se trouve à tripoli et qui
est largement dominé par les forces
politiques islamistes
le deuxième est la chambre des
représentants basés à tobrouk et
représentant principalement les courants
libéraux et fédéraliste seul pouvoir
législatif reconnu par l'onu
elle s'appuie sur le soutien de l'armée
nationale libyenne
dirigé par le maréchal haftar qui
s'opposent au pouvoir du cgn et mènent
des attaques contre les positions des
milices islamistes et des groupes
radicaux
c'est dans ce chaos sécuritaire et
institutionnel que survient la première
tentative de l'onu de mettre fin à la
division du pays en décembre 2015
les représentants des deux parlements
signe sous médiation de l'onu l'accord
de skhirat
il prévoit la formation d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale présidé
par fayez al sa rage pourtant la
composition du futur cabinet soumis au
parlement de tobrouk pour validation est
rejeté à deux reprises
la raison est le refus dalle sa rage de
voir haftar dans son gouvernement
malgré l'absence du feu vert de tobrouk
le gouvernement d'union national
s'installe en 2016 à tripoli bénéficiant
du soutien de l'onu
or il reste faible du point de vue
militaire
il se voit obligé de compter sur les
milices locales
profitant de ce fait khalifa haftar
lancent des attaques contre les forces
de son adversaire et le reprend le
contrôle sur plusieurs installations
pétrolières un des premiers à tenter la
médiation entre al sa rage et haftar et
emmanuel macron qui invite les deux
antagonistes à paris en juillet 2017
résultat ils s'accordent sur une
déclaration commune évoquant notamment
un cessez le feu et la tenue des
élections législatives et présidentielle
au printemps 2010 8
et si les affrontements entre les deux
camps deviennent rares l'organisation du
scrutin s'avère impossible compte tenu
du chaos qui règne dans le pays en mai
2010 huit nouvelles rencontres toujours
à paris il s'agit du sommet
international sur la libye auquel
participent une vingtaine d'états les
parties en conflit tombent d'accord sur
la préparation des bases
constitutionnelles
jusqu'au 16 septembre 2018 ainsi que sur
l'organisation des élections
le 10 décembre 2018
des engagements qui reste pourtant
lettre morte tripoli devient le théâtre
de combats entre les milices locales sur
fond d'activité terroriste en hausse en
mars 2010neuf l'onu tente tant bien que
mal de démarrer le dialogue politique en
annonçant une conférence de dialogue
national à ghadamès en libye avec la
participation de tous les acteurs du
pays
ces projets sont pourtant enterrée par
le maréchal haftar qui lance en avril
2019 une offensive sur tripoli sous
prétexte de lutte antiterroriste la
tension monte d'un cran
en deux mois de combats les troupes du
maréchal haftar atteignait les banlieues
de tripoli mais n'arrive quand même pas
à rentrer dans la ville les positions
des deux camps se fige et les
affrontements continuent début 2020
plusieurs tentatives sont entreprises
afin de mettre fin au conflit
d'abord c'est l'initiative russo turque
ensuite une conférence internationale à
berlin
pourtant pas de grande avancée au rendez
vous or la turquie jette de l'huile sur
le feu en envoyant au mois de janvier
ces experts militaires et membres des
forces spéciales en libye
en quelques mois seulement le gnr pousse
les forces daft art de la région de
tripoli et annonce une offensive sur la
ville de syrte
c'est le tour de l'egypte alliés daf
tarde d'entrer dans le jeu en juin le
président égyptien abdel fattah al-sisi
menace d'une intervention en cas d'
avancée des forces du gn à vers syrte
la perspective d'un conflit direct entre
ankara et le caire relance les efforts
diplomatiques pour apaiser les tensions
le 21 août fayez al sa rage et aguila
saleh le président du parlement basée à
tobrouk signe deux communiqués distincts
appelant à la cessation des combats sur
tout le territoire
s'ensuivent les négociations entre les
militaires des deux côtés qui
aboutissent à la signature de l'accord
du cessez le feu le 23 octobre
presque dix ans après le renversement de
kadhafi la libye reste plongé dans la
guerre civile si le conflit ne cesse de
s'éterniser c'est aussi à cause de
l'appui de plusieurs acteurs
internationaux aux deux parties d'abord
discret ce soutien est de plus en plus
manifeste ainsi l'egypte s'allie avec
khalifa haftar depuis 2014 le care
fournit à khalifa haftar une assistance
diplomatique et militaire
selon plusieurs médias celle ci implique
un entraînement des troupes en un appui
aérien et même des livraisons d'armes au
maréchal aide qui est clandestine
jusqu'en juillet 2020 après une roquette
du parlement de l'est libyen
le parlement de l'egypte valide
officiellement une intervention
militaire en libye
le monde retient son souffle mais le
caire décide finalement de retenir ses
troupes au demeurant l'egypte promet
clairement de passer à l'action et si
les troupes dans sa rage franchi une
ligne rouge c'est à dire que si elle
devait avancer à l'est vers la ville de
syrte sa réponse là serait immédiate la
détermination du caire et salué en
arabie saoudite et aux émirats arabes
unis
les deux sont hostiles à elle sa rage
qu'il considère comme trop proche des
frères musulmans et leur soutien
ne se limiterait pas seulement à des
déclarations diplomatiques
d'après les médias régionaux des émirats
assurerait d'abord le financement des
campagnes militaires du général atta
s'y ajoutent des livraisons d'armes y
compris des blindés des systèmes de
missiles et des aéronefs de combat une
violation apparente de l'embargo de
l'onu sur la libye condamné par ailleurs
par le conseil de sécurité
de plus selon la bbc et abu dhabi
fournira un appui aérien à khalifa
haftar grâce à des drones est selon les
médias locaux auraient contribué à créer
une unité navale
des combattants libyens avec l'egypte
quant à l'arabie saoudite
elle reste plus loin de l'action en
effet et ryad mais son poids
diplomatique derrière haftar en mars
le bar et challes est accueilli un homme
d'état par le roi salman lui même et
pendant la même rencontre le royaume
aurait promis des dizaines de millions
de dollars à khalifa haftar pour son
offensive sur tripoli
ryad et abu dhabi ne cesse de nier leur
assistance directe au maréchal cependant
les accusations se multiplient
selon une enquête du monde publié en
janvier les saoudiens auraient financé
entre autres la société militaire privée
eurus wagner qui interviendrait aux
côtés de la star
en décembre les émirats sont pointés du
doigt pour la même chose par washington
l'implication présumée de mercenaires
russes est très médiatisée mais reste
malgré tout opaque la présence de wague
guerre en libye évoqué d'abord en 2018
par les médias britanniques et
américains l'intérêt est russe il serait
économique
haftar aurait promis à moossou l'accès
aux marchés énergétiques les biens et à
ses terminaux pétroliers
de son côté moscou nie catégoriquement
d'être à l'origine d'une intervention de
wagner et souligne que celle ci est une
société purement privée nous soulignons
qu'en ce moment aucun militaire russe
n'est présent dans la zone des
hostilités en libye
de telles fausses informations vista
créé la fausse impression d'une
intervention présumé de moscou dans le
conflit libyen
aux côtés de l'une des parties les
alliances militaires de khalifa haftar
est largement clandestine
entre temps son rival de tripoli fayez
al sa rage est ouvertement appuyé par le
qatar et surtout la turquie ankara
s'impose auprès de sa rage dès l'été
2010 9 tripoli est alors assiégé par
haftar mais réussi à résister grâce à
l'aide de la turquie en novembre
ankara signent un traité militaire avec
tripoli commencent à entraîner ses
troupes et à lui vendre ouvertement des
armes janvier 2020 à la roquette dalle
sa rage la turquie envoie en libye ses
conseillers militaires
de plus selon plusieurs médias et ong et
on voit à l'appui d'al saraï plusieurs
milliers de mercenaires résultats
avaient rejoint les forces d'al saraï
repousse définitivement haftar de
tripoli et récupère plusieurs villes
stratégiques en soutenant l sa rage
ankara cherche à protéger ses intérêts
économiques
cette alliance lui ouvre l'accès à
d'immenses réserves d'hydrocarbures en
novembre 2019 et sarah gr douane si un
accord sur la délimitation des
frontières turco libyenne
celui ci aux trois ans car à de larges
zones revendiquées par chypre et la
grèce
un vrai eldorado gazier malgré les vives
protestations de l'union européenne la
turquie explorent déjà ses réserves
et pour cause l'idée a encore plus sa
présence elle annonce en outre la
construction d'une base navale sur la
côte libyenne
cette défiance turc en méditerranée ne
cesse d'irriter l'union européenne et la
politique libyenne d'ankara aggrave
encore plus les tensions en septembre
bruxelles multiplie les efforts
européenne en vue d'un règlement en
libye
en parallèle air douanes discutent du
cessez le feu avec moscou ce qui n'est
pas du tout du goût de bruxelles
dans des conflits comme celui du haut
karabagh en libye ou encore en syrie
nous observons une sorte d'astre
alisation des conflits régionaux qui
mène à l'exclusion de l'europe du
règlement des conflits régionaux en
faveur de la russie et de la turquie
ainsi depuis fin mars les forces
européennes patrouille la méditerranée
inspecte régulièrement les navires
suspects le but est d'arrêter les
livraisons d'armes turc à la libye or
celle ci continue et font enrager
l'europe
surtout la france déjà à couteaux tirés
avec ankara du coup la france est à la
pointe du sujet les biens elle exige
l'arrêt des provocations turc envoie des
rafales en méditerranée et promet des
sanctions européennes seul problème
toutes ces pressions ne semble pas
affecter la politique turque en libye et
l'union européenne
mattel plus de levier face à air douanes
avec la transition politique en vue
quelles sont les approches des autres
puissances impliquées dans ce conflit
pour mieux comprendre si on peut
attendre un apaisement libye nous
revenons vers david rigaud les roses
chercheur à l'ifan chercheur associé à
l'iris et rédacteur en chef de la revue
orient stratégie monsieur rigoler rose
la france l'allemagne et d'autres pays
menace de sanctions tous ceux qui
cherchent à empêcher le processus de
paix la turquie qui soutient
militairement à sa rage et va-t-elle
suivre leurs règles oui alors
effectivement la question des sanctions
est présidente également parce que
d'ailleurs récemment un bateau turc qui
a été arraisonné par par l'allemagne
ce qui a suscité des tensions puisque
sas a entraîné une réaction irritée de
d'ankara c'est la question effectivement
du comité des sanctions de la résolution
1970 de l'onu
cette surveillance est essentiel parce
que et elle est censée pouvoir justement
stabiliser la situation sur le terrain
en évitant l'arrivée de mercenaires qui
est qui est avérée de
puis depuis plusieurs mois et et de mu
et de j'allais dire de d'armement pour
alimenter le conflit
donc cette question des sanctions aux
contres par rapport aux contrevenants
violations justement a été extrêmement
importante et on peut noter d'ailleurs
que ça c'est dans le prolongement de la
conférence de berlin de janvier dernier
et qu'il se trouve que berlin
aujourd'hui tu as la tête justement du
comité en question
parlons de khalifa haftar et de ses
soutiens à lui en 2019
il a presque repris la ville de tripoli
quel est son but aujourd'hui l'âge
évoqué tout à l'heure la position un peu
affaibli du général du maréchal haftar
puisque effectivement son objectif
proclamé c'était là de s'emparer de
tripoli et finalement ça a été un échec
militaire malgré les soutiens dont il
bénéficie donc on peut rappeler que
effectivement le gouvernement reconnu
par le comité international d'al sa rage
et est soutenu ouvertement par la
turquie qui a fait la différence
d'ailleurs sur le terrain et qui a été
un rôle déterminant pour empêcher la
prise de contrôle de tripoli alors même
que justement ses alliés notamment les
gilts en l'occurrence avait avait
soutenu la démarche du maréchal haftar
mais l'egypte aujourd'hui considèrent
qu' il faut éventuellement avoir d'autre
option que la personne même du maréchal
haftar et derrière derrière d'ailleurs
le soutien de l'egypte il ya également
la question du soutien des émirats de la
russie on on l'a dit donc il ya un jeu
un jeu d'acteurs internationaux qui a
qui interviennent aussi dans le
processus en cours et qui sera
déterminant pour paulo finalisé et est
justement mais quel sera ce jeu dans ce
processus
pensez vous que les soutiens de
khalifa haftar comme l'egypte ou par
exemple l'arabie saoudite peuvent passer
à une participation militaire ouverte
pour défendre leurs intérêts où vont-ils
aller pour jusqu'où peuvent-ils aller
pour contrer la turquie n'ont donc d'une
certaine manière le front a été gelé
d'ailleurs ça fait l'objet dé négocier
des tractations des délégations
respectives pour entériner le gel du
front au niveau de la ville de syrte
notamment donc la question d'une
certaine manière militaire est acté
après le problème sur les modalités de
transactionnel en termes politiques et
l'egypte n'a jamais dit qu'elle avait
l'intention de faire la guerre de
manière sauf sauf si évidemment c'est un
enjeu de sécurité nationale était été
mis en cause directement
l'egypte est plutôt dans une logique de
dissuasion et si ce qui a été pour
partie d'ailleurs à l'origine de la
stabilisation du front lors en juin
dernier
merci beaucoup david rigoulet roze je
rappelle vous êtes chercheur à l'ifan
chercheur associé à l'iris et rédacteur
en chef de la revue orient stratégique
merci d'avoir apporté votre analyse dans
cette émission aujourd'hui cette partie
là n'est pas encore terminée la semaine
prochaine une nouvelle partie vous
attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial alors à bientôt sur
rt france
[Musique]